in this video we'll discuss how to
handle a canceled subscription and how
to help a user restore their
subscription if they want before we
begin you'll want to have real-time
developer notifications set up to learn
how to do this be sure to check out our
real-time developer notifications video
with real-time developer notifications
you'll receive a notification when a
subscription is cancelled or restored
after receiving this notification call
the Google Play Developer API from your
server to record the new subscription
information when a subscription is
cancelled the user retains access to
your service until the end of the
billing period during this time you can
offer the user the option to restore
their subscription before the expiration
you need to enable this functionality
via the Google Play console sign into
your play console and select your app on
the Left menu click Store presence in
app products select the subscriptions
tab and expand the subscription settings
section check the box allow users to
restore subscriptions then provide a
message in your app that tells the user
that their subscription has expired or
will expire soon be sure to include a
deep link to the Google Play
subscription Center in this message so
they can restore their subscription or
fix their payment method for more
information on setting up deep links
visit the link on screen
the message should be respectful of the
user's decision to cancel so it should
be easy to ignore and easy for the user
to permanently dismiss this notice to
learn more visit the link on screen or
check out our other videos